[Music]
screen junkies show with how Rudnick
welcome back to another honey booboo
free edition of the screen junkies show
you know in life I like to challenge
wrongdoers spit in the eye of the man
call people on their crap but I don't
like being a straight-up ahold folks so
that's why I've enlisted the biggest day
hole I know Kevin brew ik as our new
chief prank correspondent Kevin good to
be your help as we all know there's no
one more powerful in the universe than a
Jedi Master
so my pal Roman Atwood and I decided to
use the Force to really put people I
want to give any spoilers or anything
but how close did you guys come to
actually getting beaten up out there I'd
say as close as Luke and Leia came to
incest Rose
[Music]
that is not the bike you are looking for
you do not need this bike he's not the
Bulldog we're looking pretty sure I am
the owner of this bicycle you give us
the bike of your own free will
please would you like to have a drink
sometime why don't you come join us for
a drink I know a great cantina we're
meeting hon later on guys are going to
Cabo yes you need big dick oh wait you
don't want to can I use your saving the
Kindle wait can we fight would you like
to take a picture one two he did not
steal your phone there's no need to run
do not run away bring him with you
nothing is wrong the problems are alive
within you what model droid is this r2
are you in there if you will both give
me a kiss on the cheek one kiss is all I
require pass yeah I'll take a picture
get over the shoulder shoulder to
shoulder
oh nice one
I am NOT the Droid you're looking for
you don't be somebody's you know get up
out my face girl I think you need to
chill out you will look at me with love
as a brother to another is this bus go
to Alderaan ah are you gonna vote for
Obama nice guy that just sat down next
to me are you a Democrat you bet I you
will vote for Mitt Romney
oh god no sing
I must sing that you're
daddy would be [ __ ] and you're
allowed to walk by and cuss pee well
you're allowed to do that right you will
give me this hat you give us these hats
of a free
[Music]
Dickens
peewit
please we'll lose the aggression sky you
will hang up with the nursing here
please I'm going to leave
I need you to calm down sir you will
give me your phone number
don't think just do it you're burning
with desire for the both of us
this lady knows what I'm talking about
well that was ballsy and
thought-provoking thanks to Kevin brew
ik and his fellow Jedi prankster Roman
Atwood those dudes do a lot of funny
stuff so check out their channels here
oh wait so since I had to stay here in
the office I thought I'd send you off
with a new little segment hey bull
comment of the week I don't know if I
like that Ryan right now says fire the
annoying host he's terrible Ryan right
now
more like Ryan wrong always I don't come
down to your job at the booger-eating
factory and slap the boogers out of your
mouth so ease up off the gas okay hey
I'm looking to give away some of the
crap that's here on my wall so subscribe
leave a funny comment the one that makes
us laugh the most he's gonna get a prize
read the details in the description
below I'm Hal Rudnick bye bye 2009 a
screening was held this audience was the
first to experience a new or phenomenon
what they saw left them bored really
really bored normal activity